ce couple d'ukrainiens vient de franchir
la frontière polonaise visiblement
épuisé par le voyage
comme depuis le début de l'invasion
russe en ukraine ils sont des milliers à
emprunter quotidiennement ce point de
passage l'un des plus fréquentés du pays
pour trouver refuge en pologne je ne
voulais pas partir je ne voulais pas
quitter mon pays parce que j étais
heureuse avec ma famille
j'avais une belle vie
avec l'arrivée de flux de 700000
ukrainien sur son territoire depuis le
début de l'invasion russe la pologne est
l'état qui accueille le plus grand
nombre de réfugiés le pays s'est
d'ailleurs engagé à poursuivre cette
mission le chef de la diplomatie
américaine sur place a promis samedi une
aide supplémentaire de près de 3
milliards de dollars pour y parvenir
mais les autres voisins de l'ukraine la
hongrie la slovaquie ou encore la
moldavie font également preuve d'une
grande solidarité comme ici à palanca
côté moldave où l'écrasante majorité des
ukrainiens qui arrivent sont des femmes
et des enfants des hommes ont été
réquisitionnés pour combattre les
soldats russes ils sont venus dans ma
ville et dans d'autres villes du crem
ils lancent des bombes et ils détruisent
même les bâtiments résidentiels pas
seulement des complexes militaires
pour le moment plus d'un million trois
cent mille ukrainiens ont déjà quitté
leur pays pour échapper à la guerre
selon l'onu ce chiffre pourrait
atteindre les 4 minutes